der fraktionen der cdu/csu ja vielen
dank claudia davis und wir sind zurück
hier im deutschen bundestag
tatsächlich gab einige abstimmungen ich
darf sie noch mal sozusagen auf den
stand der dinge bringen
der mindestlohn die erhöhung auf 12 euro
ab oktober die ist hier beschlossen
worden mit den mehrheiten die ampel
fraktion hat natürlich dafür bestimmt
auch die linke hat dafür gestimmt cdu
csu fdp haben sich enthalten
mittlerweile ist auch das
haushaltsgesetz in zweiter beratung
abgestimmt und es wird gerade abgestimmt
über die aussetzung der schuldenbremse
denn die muss ja bevor das
haushaltsgesetz in gänze hier
verabschiedet werden kann am nachmittag
erst einmal ausgesetzt werden das zum
dritten mal damit diese neuverschuldung
von
139 milliarden euro für 2022 die
zweithöchste in der
bundesrepublikanischen geschichte
überhaupt statthaft ist so jetzt kommt
gleich die schlussrunde hier zum
haushaltsgesetz noch einmal ungefähr
anderthalb stunden aussprache und für
ihre zeitliche orientierung legen ja
kurz nach 14 uhr gibt es dann hier die
debatte zum 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr und
auch natürlich zu der dazugehörigen
grundgesetzänderung das also hier im
verlauf des weiteren nachmittages und am
ende des nachmittages wird auch noch mal
über die rentenanpassung debattiert
werden jetzt aber die schlussrunde zum
haushaltsgesetz es beginnt alexander
dobrindt
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
diese abschlussdebatte heute ist auch
deswegen so besonders und dann ja man
muss sagen sie ist historisch weil sie
mit einer grundgesetzänderung zur
finanzierung der bundeswehr verbunden
ist und deswegen bin ich auch an dieser
stelle
zu beginn ausdrücklich dank sagen es ist
uns zu beginn dieser woche
sonntagnacht gelungen eine vereinbarung
zwischen der ampel regierung und der cdu
csu fraktion zu schließen die man in den
vergangenen jahren oder jahrzehnten
eigentlich nicht für möglich gehalten
hätte 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr
und das erreichen des zwei prozent ziel
der nato da darf man ausdrücklich dank
sagen
ich möchte mich bedanken beim
bundesfinanzminister der als
verhandlungsführer für die ampel mit mir
eine ausgesprochen vertrauensvolle
zusammenarbeit gezeigt hatte ich will
mich auch beim bundeskanzler bedanken
manche herr bundeskanzler aus der ampel
haben ihre rede vom 27 februar zwar als
debattenbeitrag verstanden wir
allerdings waren der einschätzung dass
sie in diesen punkten sehr konkret waren
und ich will mich auch ausdrücklich bei
spd und grünen bedanken ich weiß dass
das für eine reihe von ihnen ein sehr
weiter weg zu gehen ist aber es ist ein
notwendiger weg der gegangen werden muss
es ist ein signal an unsere streitkräfte
ein signal an die soldatinnen und
soldaten aus der mitte dieses parlaments
wir stehen zu euch
dennoch wissen wir diese debatte auch
dafür sorgen dass klarheit über die
vereinbarungen herrscht erstens diese
100 milliarden weil das ja immer wieder
auch in dieser woche in zweifel gezogen
worden ist stehen ausschließlich für die
bundeswehr zur verfügung ja die grünen
haben ihre forderung aufgegeben das geld
an anderer stelle für andere ministerien
und für andere aufgaben zu verwenden
aufgegeben ja das ist ein klares signal
für aufrüstung und für ausrüstung und ja
wir haben beschlossen dass ein
finanzierungsgesetz dafür sorgt dass das
zwei prozent der nato das nato ziel
erreicht wird und deswegen auch hier das
klare signal an die spd an den
fraktionsvorsitzenden mütze nicht die
zwei prozent die sie diese woche noch
als eine absurde zahl bezeichnet haben
ist unser klares signal an
bündnisfähigkeit an verlässlichkeit und
an verteidigungsfähigkeit das ist das
was in diesem gesetz steht
und weiter ist da drin formuliert und
das ist auch so bedeutsam an dieser
stelle und historisch will ich sagen
dass nach der ausgrabung der 100
milliarden werden aus dem bundeshaushalt
weiterhin die finanziellen mittel
bereitgestellt um den deutschen beitrag
zu den geltenden nato fähigkeit zielen
zu gewährleisten das ist das deutliche
signal dass es nach der verschreibung
dieser 100 milliarden keine abbruchkante
geben darf sehr geehrter herr
finanzminister wir werden genau darauf
schauen ob sie das auch in ihrer
mittelfristigen finanzplanung abbilden
können und damit auch darüber klarheit
besteht die dato ziele dauerhaft zu
gewährleisten
in anbetracht der sicherheitspolitischen
lage in anbetracht der erwartungen
unserer bündnispartner in anbetracht von
erweiterten fähigkeit vielen der
bundeswehr heißt das doch eindeutig
zukünftig mehr als zwei prozent
investieren und nicht weniger damit wir
auch da grasen
sehr geehrter bundesfinanzminister sie
haben uns diese woche mitgeteilt
wörtlich wir müssen wieder lernen als
staat mit dem geld zu arbeiten dass die
menschen uns zur verfügung stellen wann
fangen sie endlich damit an
wir haben
heute von ihnen vorgelegt
ausgaben zu beschließen von 500
milliarden euro bei gleichzeitig 300
milliarden schulden er
bundesfinanzminister das ist kein
haushalt das ist ein schuldenberg und
genauso muss er bezeichnet werden
300 milliarden schulden das ist übrigens
genau so ziemlich genau der
gesamtschulden haushalt von der die
gesamtschulden von
1990 die ampel schaffte es in nur einem
jahr so viele schulden zu machen wie die
regierung adenauer bis helmut kohl in 40
jahren zusammen dass es hier ergebnis
und jetzt erzählen sie uns von der ampel
dass sie 20 23 wieder einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt erreichen wollen
der bundesfinanzminister ich nehme ihnen
das auch ab dass sie das wollen ihre
koalition will das aber ganz
offensichtlich nicht jeden tag diese
woche haben die minister der ampel neue
zusätzliche ausgaben angekündigt chen
letzten umbau der landwirtschaft
zweistelliger milliarden betrag den sie
feser neue superbehörde zweistelliger
milliarden-betrag hubertus heil soziales
klima geld dem milliarden-betrag kennt
er nicht mal selber sie wollen besser
mit dem geld umgehen und lernen dass man
nicht auszukommen was ihnen die menschen
zur verfügung stellt nein sie arbeiten
mit den schulden der kommenden
generationen die sollen das bezahlen das
ist das was ich tun
herr bundeskanzler
sie haben in ihrer rede diese woche das
thema inflation
angesprungen wir sind dankbar dafür dass
sie das thema angenommen haben
allerdings möchte ich darauf hinweisen
wir haben aktuell bereits acht prozent
inflation bei unserem nachbarn in europa
sehen wir teilweise schon mehr als 10
die gewerblichen erzeugerpreise in
deutschland steigen aktuell um
33 prozent das ist der klare vorbote
dass die konsumpreise in deutschland
auch dieses jahr zweistellig werden der
amerikanische präsident hat die
inflation zum top thema gemacht das war
sie in ihrer rede angekündigt haben ist
eine konzertierte aktion sehr geehrter
herr bundeskanzler eine konzertierte
aktion füllt eine kühlschränke und zahlt
keine stromrechnung wir brauchen keine
runde tische sondern klare ergebnisse an
dieser stelle
ich rate ihnen bauen sie die kalte
progression abschaffen sie
wettbewerbsfähige unternehmen steuern
und beenden sie ihre politik einer
europäischen schulden union nehmen sie
diesen ratschlag an ansonsten gehen sie
die gefahr ein dass sie in einem jahr
als bundeskanzler der bundesrepublik
deutschland mehr inflation geschaffen
haben als angela merkel in 16 jahren
auch das ist die wahre und
jetzt will ich an dieser stelle auch
weil wir ja vor pfingsten stehen auch
noch was persönliches sagen
ich werde mir jetzt ein 9 euro ticket
kaufen für meine reise nach rügen weil
nach sylt fahren ja die ganzen linken
hätten sie klaus ganz gefragt dann
hätten sie festgestellt dass teure an
sylt ist nicht die deutsche bahn sondern
der champagner an der sansibar
herzlichen glückwunsch
also ob er über die pfingst urlaubspläne
hier noch mehr erfahren in dieser
schlussrunde mal schauen aber ein
bisschen attacke hier vom
csu-landesgruppenchef alexander dobrindt
hier zum auftakt dieser schlussrunde da
wird noch mal alles ausgepackt natürlich
diese
haushaltsdebatte ja sehr dominiert
natürlich von der debatte rund um das
100 milliarden euro sondervermögen für
die bundeswehr was jetzt zusätzlich zum
haushalt hier aufgenommen wird deswegen
eben sondervermögen darüber wird heute
im weiteren verlauf des nachmittages
debattiert und abgestimmt das ist
zunächst die schlussrunde aber natürlich
sie haben es gemerkt die team überlagern
sich karsten klein hören wir jetzt von
der fdp
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte
erstmal mit einem dunk beginnen für die
kollegiale zusammenarbeit während den
haushaltsberatungen an die
oppositionsfraktionen aber vor allem
natürlich an die kolleginnen und
kollegen der koalitionsfraktion denn uns
ist es gemeinsam gelungen in diesen
ersten regierungsentwurf der noch von
der großen koalition ausgehandelt war
das zarte pflänzchen des aufbruchs und
des fortschritts einzupflanzen das haben
wir den haushaltsberatungen ordentlich
mit wasser
aufgepäppelt und mit wachstums mitteln
ausgestattet und so wichtige
weichenstellungen im sinne unseres
koalitionsvertrags auf dem weg war wir
stärken mit diesem haushalt die
innovationskraft deutschlands wir
bringen wichtige projekte und maßnahmen
für transformation digitalisierung
bekämpfung des klimawandels auf den weg
wir stellen investitionsmittel in höhe
von
51,5 milliarden euro zur verfügung alles
um die zukunft dieses landes zu
gestalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
zur gesamtblick gehört aber auch dass
diese koalition mit diesem einzelnen mit
diesem haushalt zwei enorme
herausforderungen abbildet das hat es in
der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland noch nicht gegeben und
deshalb darf man diesen kraftakt nicht
zu selten betonen in diesem haushalt und
damit hier keine falschen fan stehen
bleiben herr kollege so bringt der
übrigens im kernhaushalt 400 95,8
milliarden euro um fast 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen und eine
neuverschuldung in höhe von 138 9
milliarden euro plus 100 milliarden also
nur damit hier keine falschen zahlen
stehen bleiben aber in diesem haushalt
sind natürlich auch nochmal enorme
kosten der korea-krise abgebildet und
zum beispiel für den herbst vorzubeugen
im bereich von impfstoffversorgung dass
wir vorbereitet sind für den herbst aber
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen diese
impfstoffe werden natürlich nicht nur
auf sylt eingesetzt werden sondern in
der gesamten bundesrepublik deutschland
damit alle durch den herbst kommen aber
in diesem haushalt stehen auch noch
einmal enorme mittel fürs testen und
deshalb möchte ich an dieser stelle im
hinblick auf den beschluss der mpk von
gestern noch mal darauf hinweisen
ganz höflich die bundesregierung ist an
beschlüsse dieses deutschen bundestages
gebunden und deshalb geht es kein weiter
so bei dem bürger in tests nach dem 30
06 gegen und an dieser stelle möchte ich
auch für einen strategiewechsel werden
wir haben mehr steuereinnahmen auf
seiten der länder 55 milliarden euro
gehen auf dem boot aus dem
bundeshaushalt zu den ländern und wenn
wir es kein strategiewechsel in hinblick
auf die länder einführen werden wir in
diesem haus in zukunft nur noch über die
zuschüsse zu den sozialversicherungen
und zu den ländern diskutieren das kann
so nicht beiden deshalb müssen wir hier
einen strategiewechsel einführen
neben dem kernhaushalt bilden wir im
ergänzungs hause an die
herausforderungen zur ukraine zur
ukraine krieg ab entlastungen für die
bürgerinnen und bürger erhöhen die
unabhängigkeit von fossilen russischen
energieträgern und über das
sondervermögen wir das ja später
diskutiert wird nehmen wir 100
milliarden euro für die
verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses landes in
die hand ich glaube wir machen mit
diesem haushalt deutlich dass wir als
koalition spd grünen und fdp in
schwierigen zeiten handlungsfähig sind
und die weichen in richtung zukunft
stellen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich mache
darauf aufmerksam dass die zeit für die
namentliche abstimmung um 12 uhr 52
vorbei ist bitte also diejenigen die
noch nicht gelegenheit hatten
abzustimmen in jedem fall wird die
abstimmung nach dem nächsten redner
geschlossen polen möchte ich aber
gelegenheit nehmen die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter des sekretariats des
haushaltsausschusses hier wurde auf der
bundesbank zu begrüßen
sie sehen das gesamte haus
anerkennung für ihre arbeit und
die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter des
haushalts des sekretariats des
haushaltsausschusses folgen
traditionsgemäß der
schlussrunde hier im saal auch das soll
der anerkennung natürlich ihre tätigkeit
dienen wie erfahre seine schöne geste
hier auch von den abordnungen aus dem
ganzen haus gab es entsprechend beifall
für die mitarbeiter des
haushaltsausschusses die ja immer
gefordert sind aber in den letzten
wochen noch umso mehr peter böhringer
für die afg spricht ist
frau präsidentin den dank an die
mitarbeiter mitarbeiterinnen haben sie
uns vorweggenommen ein tiefpunkt der
zurückliegenden haushaltsberatungen war
sicherlich dass sich die alte fraktion
in der nacht der bereinigungssitzung
nochmals 30 millionen euro mehr für ihre
parteinahen stiftungen genehmigt haben
das bringt die summe nun auf völlig
überdimensionierte 600 millionen euro
pro jahr
positiv kam er zwar anmerken dass alle
fraktionen nun einen rechtsstaat tüv für
diese stiftung einführen wollen noch
darauf liebe kollegen hätten sie doch
schon erheblich früher kommen müssen bei
hunderten von titeln im haushalt über
die zumeist linke organisation auch ohne
verfassungs bekenntnis finanziert werden
linke gruppen werden immer großzügig
bedient sogar wenn sie sich weigern
extremismusklausel zu unterschreiben und
dass sich der haushaltsausschuss als
legislative organ dann hat auch noch
ernsthaft zur judikative aufschwingt
und exklusiv genau jene sechs stiftungen
der sechs altparteien zur
verfassungstreue erklärt alle anderen
aber nicht obwohl selbst reden keiner
entsprechenden urteile oder verfahren
des verfassungsgerichtes in irgendeiner
weise vorliegen lässt einen schon
fassungslos zurück sie wissen dass sie
damit die kompetenzen der legislative
überschritten hatten und machen und
machen es trotzdem
eine beurteilung der verfassungstreue
wäre natürlich die aufgabe des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gewesen dem
haushaltsausschuss steht das aufstellen
einer solchen positivliste nicht zu ihr
vorgehen war ein bruch der
gewaltenteilung sie legen es sehenden
auges auf eine gericht die gerichtliche
niederlage des bundestages vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht an
beim ergänzungs haushalt wurde uns
erzählt er beträgt wenn nur die folgen
des so kleine konflikt fakt ist aber
dass er auch milliardenschwer budget für
das wenig durchdachten euro ticket zb
nach süd enthält zudem impfstoff titel
und zuschüsse an medienkonzern zu den
einsparpotenzialen diesem haushalt hatte
ich an der ersten lesung schon einiges
gesagt insbesondere die unsummen an
steuermitteln die einfach so ins ausland
verteilt werden machen immer wieder
stutzig etwa die zehn thema milliarden
die der kanzler indien versprochen hat
der ukraine werden riesige blankoschecks
ausgestellt von der eu und von
deutschland was finanziell ja ohnehin
derselbe deutsche topf ist ursula von
der leyen klingt darum genau wie
ministerin schulze deutschland steht
bereit weil wiederaufbau der ukraine zu
helfen das ist ein verdammt großes wort
und vor allem derzeit steht leider noch
kein wiederaufbau an aktuell stehen aber
deutschland und die eu bereit die
kriegsschäden durch waffenlieferungen
erst einmal zu erhöhen auch über den
vorliegenden haushalt 2022 in form der
mittel für die sogenannte europäische
friedens fazilität die heißt wirklich so
und über sie finanziert deutschland über
den umweg der eu waffenlieferungen an
weltweite drittstaaten ohne angemessene
parlamentarische kontrolle hier sicher
nicht und auch nicht im eu parlament
ich erinnere in diesem zusammenhang
daran dass die verteidigungspolitik noch
nicht einmal vergemeinschaftet ist die
eu hat also eigentlich überhaupt kein
mandat für eine solche rüstungs
finanzierung
ein weiterer tiefpunkt wurde bei den
sozialversicherungssystemen erreicht
inzwischen ist dort keine einzige zeile
mehr nachhaltig aus beiträgen
finanzieren alle vier müssen inzwischen
mit über 150 milliarden euro zuschüssen
pro jahr aus steuermitteln finanziert
werden
neben der schlechten demographie und
diversen kläger anreizen dem
gesundheitssektor liegt das eindeutig
auch an der massiven zuwanderung in die
sozialsysteme die wir in den letzten
jahren gesehen haben
und die ampel will nun auch noch immer
mehr temporären migranten den vollen
sozialhilfe schutz gewährt wie
formulierte es eben erst ein grüner
kollege ganz stolz sie an dieser stelle
wir tun etwas was zuvor noch nie getan
wurde wir haben möglichen millionen von
menschen wenn sie zu uns kommen direkt
in unsere sozialsysteme zu kommen tja
der haushalt ist eben immer ein spiegel
der allgemein politik wenn derart
ideologisch gegen deutschland und die
schon länger hier leben den regiert wird
dann ist der haushaltsnotstand mit
riesiger verschuldung irgendwann die
zwingende folge
und die mega verschuldung hat eine
unvermeidbare folge inflation diese ist
nur zu einem kleinen teil folge des
ukraine kriegs denn schon seit herbst
zwei und 221 liegt die teuerungsrate
über fünf prozent inzwischen fast acht
prozent der großteil der
preissteigerungen ist die schuld der
politik massive staatsverschuldung in
europa und deutschland in verbindung mit
der monetisierung dieser gelder durch
die ezb dann klimaschutz co2 ideologie
was energie und nahrungsmittel massiv
verteuert corona maßnahmen die die
transport logistic erschweren weltweit
und das angebot verknappen zuwanderung
die die preise verwunderung nach oben
treibt bürokratie und eu planwirtschaft
eine sanktionspolitik die uns selbst am
meisten schadet sowie fehlende kontrolle
über die energie- und benzin oligopol
unternehmen all das in situation zur
sachen die afg hat fast alle diese
ursachen immer bekämpft angefangen mit
der uhr sünde des euro und der
euro-rettung genau die jetzige hoch
inflation wollten wir
stabilitätspolitiker und euro-kritiker
seit jahren verhindern leider wollen die
vereinigten linken von rot grün bis
schwarz davon seit jahrzehnten nichts
hören man profitierte ja von den
niedrigen zinsen doch irgendwann schlägt
das pendel zurück und nun steuern wir
auf die soziale katastrophe zu
verursacht durch das handeln der politik
politik biologisch voll korrekten
regierungen der letzten jahrzehnte
beziehungsweise der finanzpolitisch
radikalen selbsterklärten mitte dieses
hauses erzwingen
peter böhringer für die idee war dass
der haushaltspolitische sprecher die
namentliche abstimmung ist vorbei
gibt es noch ein mitglied des hauses
welches seine stimme nicht abgegeben hat
das ist nicht der fall ich schließe die
abstimmung und bitte die
schriftführerinnen und schriftführer mit
der auszählung zu beginnen das ergebnis
der abstimmung wird ihnen später bekannt
gegeben
im hintergrund lief ja noch die
namentliche abstimmung zum aussetzen der
schuldenbremse die er zum dritten mal
für 2022 ausgesetzt werden soll
dafür ist die mehrheit des hauses
notwendig also 736 abgeordnete gibt es
ja
und 369 müssen mindestens mit ja stimmen
damit die schuldenbremse ausgesetzt
bleibt erst dann kann ja auch über das
haushaltsgesetz abgestimmt werden weil
die neuverschuldung über der im
grundgesetz festgelegte schuldenbremse
liegt
auf das herzlichste zu bedanken und ich
bedanke mich auch bei der präsidentin
dass sie das schon hier von hier oben
aus getan hat also herzlichen dank
eine hammer kommen arbeiten große
belastung auch für die ganzen
mitarbeiter und vor allen dingen nach
dem haushalt ist ja vor dem haushalt
also das ganze machen wir ja noch einmal
aber wir sind gut im training also
vielen dank dafür herr dobrindt in hagen
entschuldigung ich hab auch ihre zeit
angehalten ich mache darauf aufmerksam
dass das fotografieren im plenum nicht
erlaubt ist und behalte mir auch vor
sollte eines dieser fotos auftauchen in
den netzwerken oder anderes dass ich die
entsprechenden
ordnungsmaßnahmen ergreife entschuldigen
sie hier aber das muss jetzt sein und
ich lasse die uhr jetzt weiterlaufen
bitteschön dankeschön frau präsidentin
herr dobrindt ich will nicht meine ganze
rede zeit darauf verwenden ihn auf das
was sie ja dargestellt haben hat das
klarzustellen mein kollege karsten klein
hat das ja auch schon gemacht habe sie
haben so viel erzählt was nicht den
tatsachen ins stimmt dass es schwierig
ist ich will nur zu einem thema was
sagen sie müssen sie schon mal
entscheiden ob sie jetzt eigentlich den
schuldenberg skandalisieren wollen oder
selbst mit ihren forderungen nach noch
viel höheren schulden und steuer sendung
als es ist die quadratur des kreises was
sie vortragen
schlüssig ist das nicht und weil sie den
vergleich gemacht haben das seit konrad
adenauer bis 1990 was dafür schulden
angesammelt worden wären hätten sie sich
das mit 100 adenauer man besser gespart
denn die ersten schulden überhaupt
wurden es 1968 gemacht und in so faden
von 1968 von 1968 bis 1990 jahre wuchs
der schuldenberg langsam auf das ist
richtig aber dann kamen die deutsche
einheit und dann hat unter kanzler kohl
nicht über schulden und nicht über was
angemessen gewesen wäre steuererhöhungen
sozial gefächert die finanzierung der
deutschen stadt
der deutschen einheit stattgefunden
sondern überbelastung der sozialen
sicherungssysteme maßgeblich der rente
und das ist übrigens mit ein hauptgrund
dafür warum der bundeszuschuss zur rente
in dem umfang in den letzten 20 jahren
steigen musste wieder gestiegen ist also
passen sie auch an dieser stelle
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
wir haben in dieser woche viel über
sicherheit gesprochen über militärische
sicherheit ja das hat die debatte
dominiert auch über innere sicherheit
die massive stärkung durch dreieinhalb
tausend stellen alleine bei
bundespolizei und zoll sind ein beispiel
dafür dass eben die bevölkerung tieren
unserem land ganz bestimmt nicht
vergessen wird mit diesem haushalt und
wir haben auch über soziale sicherheit
besprochen und das will ich noch einmal
betonen weil die debatte die wir gerade
hatten mit dem mindestlohn die ist
tatsächlich ein wichtiger beitrag nicht
nur für die menschen sondern eben auch
im rahmen des ganzen konzertes dass wir
hier mit einer einnehmen der mindestlohn
als wir den eingeführt haben zusammen
mit der union zwar zum
2015 8 euro 50 hat in meinem wahlkreis
und ich bin auf einem westlichen
bundesland schleswig-holstein
wir haben die niedrigsten löhne haben
die niedrigsten löhne in der ganzen
westlichen bundesrepublik und bei uns
haben über 22.000 menschen damals die
bis dahin für unter 6 euro 50 gearbeitet
haben von diesen mindestlohn profitiert
und insofern wird auch dieses mal weil
es ist eine strukturelle frage bei uns
leben aber in viele menschen im bereich
des tourismus des gastgewerbes und so
weiter auch auf sylt und die verdienen
eben nicht so wahnsinnig gut und die
werden ganz maßgeblich von der erhöhung
auf 12 euro mindestlohn profitieren
das sind übrigens liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ganz überwiegend frauen und
diese frauen weil herr merz der jetzt
fehlt am dienstag im seiner debatte sehr
viele fragen gestellt hat keine
vorschläge gemacht was machen hat sehr
viele fragen unter anderem hatte auf
fragen zur rente gestellt da muss man
natürlich wissen dass alle die die gut
verdienen natürlich am besten in
tarifgebundenen mögen aber mindestens
mit zwölf euro mindestlohn dass gerade
diese frauen davon zweimal profitieren
nicht nur durch einen angemessenen lohn
sondern auch durch eine verbesserte
rente
unter dobrindt hat oberen zum thema
rente muss man ja sagen dass dadurch
dass wir in den letzten 20 jahren so
lange gesagt diesem haus an maßgeblich
etwas getan haben dafür gesorgt haben
dass immer mehr frauen auch arbeiten
gehen konnten weil wir zum beispiel die
betreuung der kinder verbessert haben
die ganztagsbetreuung eingeführt haben
dass das natürlich jetzt auch mithilft
dem fachkräftemangel entgegenzuwirken
den wir haben und es ist noch ein
anderes stichwort wir brauchen natürlich
mehr zuwanderung geregelte zuwanderung
damit die größte gefahr für eine
prosperierende wirtschaft in den
nächsten zehn jahren ermöglicht dass in
den griff bekommen und wenn wir mehr
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer wir
haben die gut bezahlt haben um so besser
ist unsere rente gesichert führend und
bettina hagedorn die stellvertretende
vorsitzende des haushaltsausschusses
hier in der schlussrunde
und als nächste erhält das wort doktor
gesine lötzsch ja und im
bundestagspräsidium gab es einen wechsel
aydan özoguz
leitete die sitzung
sehr geehrten damen und herren viel wird
von zeitenwende gesprochen aber
eigentlich geht es um etwas anderes es
geht um einen politikwechsel
spd und grüne haben den wählerinnen und
wählern vor der wahl soziale
gerechtigkeit versprochen aber ich frage
sie wie geht es weiter mit der
kindergrundsicherung wo ist das
bürgergeld warum haben sie das
verschoben meine damen und sie hatten
auch eine vermögenssteuer ins
wahlprogramm geschrieben vermögenssteuer
haben sie jetzt schon über bord geworfen
und ich stelle ihnen die frage wenn sie
ernsthaft behaupten wollen dass sie 20
23 herr linder die schuldenbremse
einhalten wollen wie und wovon sollen
diese sozialpolitischen projekte
finanziert werden die antwort darauf
schuldig geblieben und das in den wenig
hin
meine damen und herren in dieser woche
wurde auch viel über den krieg gegen die
ukraine gesprochen und wir als linke
sagen dieser krieg muss sofort beendet
werden die erste schritt dazu ist ein
waffenstillstand dafür muss die
bundesregierung alles tun um das
durchzusetzen
aber wir müssen auch über die
kriegsgewinnler sprechen wenn wir uns
vor augen führen dass der
panzerhersteller rheinmetall sich noch
im jahr 2014 und da gab es schon einen
krieg in der ukraine gegen die ukraine
die freiheit genommen hat was man an
russland und die ukraine zu liefern und
damit viel geld zu verdienen dann frage
ich mich warum ist das in diesem land
hingenommen werden so etwas muss ein
ende haben die damen und herren
und wir wissen doch auch den länger der
krieg dauert desto besser ist das für
die aktionäre von rheinmetall und auch
darum sagen wir es muss einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand geben das ist für die
menschen das beste
in der krise sind viele ärmer aber auch
viele reicher geworden und darum sagen
wir es muss endlich eine über gewinn
steuer geben wir haben das ja beantragt
als fraktion die linke hier im deutschen
bundestag
das lehnt die fdp mit dem verweis auf
den koalitionsvertrag ab da stellten
dieser koalitionsvertrag wurde vor der
von ihnen immer wieder angeführten
zeitenwende und auch sie von der fdp
haben ja dieses wort verwendet
geschlossen wir fordern sie auf ziehen
sie aus ihrer zeitenwende die
schlussfolgerung endlich eine steuer
wende zu machen meine damen und herren
die
who hat die einnahmen aus einer über
print steuer auf 200 milliarden euro
eu-weit natürlich beziffert warum frage
ich sie herr lindner wollen sie auf
dieses geld einfach verzichten ich finde
das verantwortungslos
und aufstellt ist doch gerne die
schuldenbremse gilt nur wenn es um die
sozialpolitik und die investitionen in
die friedliche zukunft geht die
schuldenbremse gilt nicht wenn es um ein
neues wettrüsten geht sie messen mit
zweierlei maß und das geht nicht
allein der rüstungs haushalt für dieses
jahr ohne die zusätzlichen 100
milliarden euro die ja dann beschlossen
werden sollen und es übrigens kein
sondervermögen sondern ist ein
zusätzlicher schulden allein der
rüstungs haushalt für dieses jahr
beträgt
50,4 milliarden euro nach nato kriterien
berechnet und es so auf 55,6 sie geben
also für militär in diesem jahr weit
mehr geld aus als insgesamt für bildung
forschung familie senioren frauen jugend
wohnungsbau und wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit das ist der falsche weg
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
einige entlastungspaket
aber es ist schon berechnet worden und
nachgewiesen wurden vom institut für
makroökonomie und konjunkturforschung
dass diese entlastungspaket völlig
aufgefressen werden und dass die
preissteigerung allein in den ersten
vier monaten des jahres mehr als die
hälfte des versprochenen entlastungen
verschlungen haben und allein leben
damit niedriger rente haben auf jeden
fall ein - die inflation hat sie jetzt
schon mehr gekostet als je an entlastung
bekommen werden und wir brauchen jetzt
ein schutzschirm rettung für die
menschen die kein geld mit krieg und
krisen verdienen das wäre die aufgabe
der bundesregierung ändern kann
nun haben sich viele schon das neuen
euro ticket gekauft und ich bin
enttäuscht dass wir beide uns nicht auf
sylt treffen können aber vielleicht
haben wir da noch eine andere
gelegenheit aber leider ist dieses
ticket ja nur ein sommertraum danach
werden wieder die vollen preise verlangt
mit nachhaltigkeit hat das wirklich
wenig zu tun im gegenteil es besteht die
gefahr dass die menschen abgeschreckt
werden und im herbst wieder aufs auto
umsteigen meine damen und herren die
wichtigsten aufgaben die erfüllt werden
müssen es erstens den frieden
wiederherzustellen
waffenstillstand sofort die armut muss
bekämpft werden und die ärmsten der
armen leiden am stärksten unter der
klimakrise und darum ums klima
der einsatz gegen die klimakrise auch
aktive armutsbekämpfung herzlichen dank
vielen dank
beruhigt die nächste rednerin aufrufe
möchte ich das protokoll dass von den
schriftführerin und schriftführer
ermittelten ergebnis der namentlichen
abstimmung verlesen über den antrag der
fraktionen spd bündnis 90/die grünen und
fdp beschluss des deutschen bundestages
gemäß artikel 115 absatz 2 satz 6 und 7
des grundgesetzes
drucksache 20 20 36 abgegebene
stimmkarten
684 mit ja haben gestimmt
398 mit nein haben gestimmt
251 enthaltungen
gemäss artikel 115 absatz 2 satz 6 des
grundgesetzes ist die mehrheit der
mitglieder erforderlich das sind
369 jahr stimmen der antrag ist mit der
erforderlichen mehrheit also angenommen
und damit
ist die schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
für 2022
ausgesetzt für dieses jahr noch einmal
das ist ja auch die voraussetzung dafür
dass der bundeshaushalt 2022 jetzt dann
nach dieser schlussrunde geschlossen
werden kann denn es gibt eine
neuverschuldung von 139 milliarden euro
und das liegt über der grenze die das
grundgesetz vorsieht
kollegen liebe mitarbeiter in den des
haushaltsausschusses auch von dieser
stelle nochmal an die großen dank der
koalitionsvertrag der ampel ist jetzt
knapp ein halbes jahr alt aber seit der
24 der kontinuierlich jeden tag updated
werden seit knapp 100 tagen gibt es
einen angriffskrieg in europa und tattoo
print ich bin zwar nur 80 geboren und
auch im osten deutschlands aber ich
glaube konrad adenauer musste genau
diese frage in seiner zeit nicht
bewältigen und deswegen mit diesen neuen
status quo müssen wir jetzt arbeiten und
dass die politik der bundesregierung
braucht ein update und dieser haushalt
so wie wir heute jetzt hier beschließen
der ist elementarer bestandteil genau
dieses updates in diesem haushalt
müssten wir als ampel auch das aus
buchstabieren was zum zeitpunkt des
koalitionsvertrages ja noch nicht mal
denkbar war wir machen konkret was im
letzten herbst komplett unwahrscheinlich
erschien denn die folgen des angriffs
tricks aus der ukraine
die schnellstmögliche unabhängigkeit von
russischen energielieferungen und
bündnisfähigkeit und auch die versorgung
ukrainischer geflüchtete und was wir
auch machen wir müssen auch das aus
buchstabieren wo fiel im letzten herbst
noch gehofft hatten dass es gar nicht
mehr eine derart große rolle spielt die
weiter anhaltenden folgen der korona
pandemie und ja auch die auswirkungen
der inflation im haushalt schafft
realitäten aber in diesem zeitmaß
deswegen auch besonders notwendig in
diesem haushalt konkretisierungen
vorzunehmen und zu erreichen wo vorher
alles vage war und für diesen großen
kraftakt und es war ein kraftakt der
ganz große dank an die haushälterinnen
und haushälter der ampel besonders und
stellvertretend an dieser stelle auch
dennis brode sven christian kindler und
otto fricke die haushälter dieser
koalition sind eines der rückgrat dieser
koalition und sie halten vieles in
dieser koalition ein ganz entscheidender
stelle zusammen aber natürlich auch über
diesem haushalt und über den folgenden
schweben weiter befragen zwei möchte
schnell die eine frage ist wir haben
nicht mehr diese klassische krise die
kommt die wird bewältigt danach setzt
die erholungsphase einer erholungsphase
die ja nicht nur erholung ist für
gesellschaft und politik sondern gerade
auch für die staatsfinanzen nicht wir
haben jetzt die situation wo die eine
krise noch nicht vorbei ist die nächste
schon kommt und wir insgesamt krieg
sehen krisen akkumulieren und die
erholungsphasen lassen lange auf sich
warten und was machen wir mit
zukunftsinvestitionen wenn wir nicht auf
diese erholungsphasen warten können das
ist die eine frage die andere auch nicht
ganz unwichtige frage ist was es
eigentlich eine faire lastenverteilung
zwischen bund und ländern in zeiten
multipler krisen ich erinnere mich an
das erste corona jahr 2020 bund und
ländern großer einigkeit beide sehr
stark in die verantwortung gegangen das
sind ambitionen die schon im letzten
jahr 20 21 deutlich auseinandergehen mit
einer deutlich stärkeren verschuldung
und verantwortungsübernahme des bundes
und in diesem jahr sehen wir der bund
geht in die vollen einmal mehr balkone
noch nicht vorbei weil die ukraine krise
so unglaublich über alles bestimmt ist
und die länder fangen an ihre haushalte
zu sanieren 11 milliarden überschuss in
den ländern und kommunen sogar schon
schuldentilgung in den ländern über 20
milliarden euro ich möchte nicht wie
manche kollegen von anderen parteien in
diesem zusammenhang von der raub und
bräuche gemeinschaft der länder sprechen
das ist ein zitat aber ich möchte doch
fragen ist die lastenverteilung zwischen
bund und ländern hier im jahr 20 21 22
grad noch im lot was versuchen wir hier
was wir hier als andere antworten zu
geben wir sagen nein wir können nicht
auf die erholungsphase warten wir müssen
jetzt auch zukunftsinvestitionen starten
milliarden für klima milliarden für den
artenschutz milliarden für humanitäre
hilfe und pandemie prävention warum weil
alles andere bedeuten würde andere
krisen noch anzuheizen und zu
beschleunigen und damit mit dafür
verantwortlich zu sein wenn
erholungsphasen sich noch weiter nach
hinten verschieben und das andere ist ja
wir brauchen in dieser zeit mit
besonders großen belastungen eine
verlässliche partnerschaft mit den
ländern und deswegen hat dieser
haushaltsausschuss auch unter anderem
die maßgabe auf den weg gebracht das die
korona test zum zweiten halbjahr 2022
nicht mehr allein vom bund zu tragen
sind deswegen ist es so besonders
bemerkenswert dass die mpk gestern
einmal mehr festgehalten hat die länder
bitten darum dass der bund es weiter
vollumfänglich übernimmt ich finde dass
es keinen start einer guten diskussion
wenn wir gebündelt diesen großen berg in
herdorf wenn es ist ja nicht nur ein
schuldenberg das ist ein berg an
aufgaben die wir als gesellschaft jetzt
bewältigen müssen und da brauchen wir
die gesamte kraft dieses landes und
nicht nur die 42 prozent steuerkraft des
bundes sondern die gesamte kraft von
bund und ländern in das theoretisch
und ich bin genau wo sind eigentlich die
wende an der stelle ich bin den vielen
kollegen sehr dankbar ich komme jetzt
auch aus einem der östlichen
bundesländer und ich find's gut dass wir
hier die debatte so ein bisschen ins lot
bringen was die vorherrschaft von sylt
angeht ich finde es unglaublich wichtig
dass knapp 30 jahre nach der
wiedervereinigung rügen usedom und
tiefensee mindestens ebenso wichtig sind
und sie sind vor allem bahntechnisch
auch heute schon deutlich besser
angebunden wenn sie noch fragen haben zu
den schönsten ostdeutschen bahnstrecken
stehen mein bewohnt ich jederzeit gern
zur verfügung damit es nur ein euro
ticket das ja so viel leisten soll für
uns als ampelkoalition auch dabei hilft
aus dem test noch einmal mehr
zusammenzubringen vielen dank
paula kirchhatter war das vierte minus
90 die grünen wie in der dritten
beratung zum haushaltsgesetz 20 22
natürlich noch mit einem hinweis auf das
9 euro ticket das jetzt in diesen drei
sommermonaten jeweils gilt jannik burri
spricht jetzt für die unionsfraktion
frau kollegin pia oder ich gebe ihnen in
einer sache ja recht das ist die
haushälter sind die diese koalition
zusammenhalten in dem es nämlich die
riesige mit geld stopfen das ist das was
wir in diesem haushalt der
haushaltsberatungen ja auch gesehen
haben das waren viele kolleginnen
kollegen meiner ersten
haushaltsberatungen die ich mitgemacht
habe und ich habe mich an der ein oder
anderen stelle ehrlich gesagt dann schon
auch mal gewundert lieber herr minister
lindner mit öffentlichen äußerungen wenn
sie sich beim ecofin rats dafür
aussprechen die sucht nach verschuldung
zu beenden wenn sie auch was ja für
vollkommen richtig halte immer
wiederholt betont dass wir 23 zur
schuldenbremse zurückkehren müssen
beides politisch ökonomisch vollkommen
richtig das problem ist leider nur dass
das was sie über haushaltspolitik reden
relativ wenig zu tun hat mit ihrem
konkreten regierungshandeln mit dem was
sie in diesem haushalt uns vorgelegt
haben
und wie sehr
diese erzählung und wirklichkeit ihrer
politik auseinander klaffen das wird
ganz besonders deutlich wenn man sich
ihr finanzpolitisches strategiepapier
man anschaut dass sie vor einigen wochen
vorgestellt haben auch da ein papier bei
dem mir als ordnungs ökonom erst mal das
herz aufgeht wenn man es durch liest bei
dem sich allerdings leider relativ
schnell dann auch ernüchterung breit
macht wenn man das was sie dort
aufgeschrieben haben mal abgleicht mit
dem was sie konkret tun sie sprechen
unter anderem von einer zitat
zielgerichteten und kurzfristigen
stabilisierung in der krise aber
brauchen dann monate um entlastungen
angesichts der steigenden inflation
vorzulegen die dann noch nicht mal
zielgerichtet sind sondern unter anderem
fahrten nach sylt subventionieren sie
preisen eine angebotsorientierte
wirtschaftspolitik und fordern unter
anderem eine diversifizierung von
lieferketten auch das ja völlig richtig
aber ihre koalition vertrag von woche zu
woche die ratifizierung des abkommens
hier im bundestag und jetzt kann ich ja
nachvollziehen dass es ihnen bei
ordnungspolitischen antworten auf die
inflation oder bei angebotsorientierte
wirtschaftspolitik nicht immer leicht
fällt sich bei ihren koalitionspartnern
durchzusetzen was ich aber beim besten
willen nicht verstehen kann ist dass sie
als dritte säule ihrer strategie
finanzpolitische residenz und stabilität
noch groß ins schaufenster stellen aber
dann einen haushalt aufstellen der das
genaue gegenteil davon ist mit 100 38,9
milliarden neue schulden internen
ergänzungs haushalt 100 milliarden
zweifellos notwendig und dringlich
sonder schulden in sondervermögen
bundeswehr und 60 milliarden euro
zusätzliche schulden im klima- und
transformations- vor die sie zwar
verfassungswidrig auf 20 21 buchen aber
in diesem jahr tatsächlich aufgenommen
haben macht in summe und da hat der
kollege drogen vor vollkommen recht
gehabt rund 300 milliarden euro schulden
die sie in 20 22 aufnehmen mit
finanzpolitische stabilität und
resilienz hat das gar nichts zu tun
und jetzt und jetzt kann man sagen was
ja auch diese woche hier auch wieder
getan wurde jeder cent dieser
verschuldung der dringend gebraucht
besonders bemerkenswert ist dann der
mann in der finanzpolitischen strategie
ein bisschen weiter liest nämlich auf
seite 21 von der ich mit erlaubnis der
präsidentin zitiere zitat es stehen im
klima- und transformations- vor und den
regulären haushalten bereits mehr mittel
zur verfügung als im aktuellen umfeld
sinnvoll ausgegeben werden können das
sage nicht ich das haben sie in ihrer
strategie oder ihr haus in ihrer
strategie so aufgeschrieben und wieder
gilt erzähle und politisches handeln
klaffen meilenweit auseinander mehr noch
angesichts des haushaltes den sie heute
hier beschließen wollen ist ihr papier
und ist auch ihre rede von
finanzpolitischen stabilität schlicht
eines unglaubwürdig und das sage ich
jetzt herr minister ja gar nicht gegen
wie mit häme im gegenteil ich bedauere
das ausdrücklich weil ich von ihnen als
finanzminister bei der frage nach
finanzieller nachhaltigkeit mehr
standhaftigkeit und ehrlich gesagt auch
mehr prinzipientreue erwartet hätte und
dass wir verstärkt durch einen tritt in
ihrer finanzplanung der stehen sie
vorgehen wollen die schuldenbremse ab 23
wieder einzuhalten tatsächlich aber auch
ihre politik nach 23 mit schulden
finanzieren sie müssen die ausnahmeregel
der schuldenbremse um jetzt am anfang
der wahlperiode schulden aufzunehmen
dieses geld verschieben sie dann in ein
nebenhaushalt aus dem heraus sich über
die gesamte wahlperiode ihre politik
mittel finanzieren in wahrheit ist so
auch die politik nach 20 23 schulden
finanziert nur dass sie eben alle
schulden auf die jahre 21 und 22 buchen
wahrscheinlich mit der hoffnung dass zum
ende der wahlperiode sich keiner mehr in
die nettokreditaufnahme am anfang der
wahlperiode erinnert
die schuldenbremse hat eines solchen
vorgehen die schulden der ganzen
wahlperiode auf einzelne jahren zu
versuchen eigentlich aus gutem grund
bislang einen riegel vorgeschoben
sie haben als eine ihrer ersten
amtshandlungen die buchungs regeln der
schuldenbremse zu ihren gunsten geändert
und diesen trick so überhaupt erst
möglich gemacht auch das macht sie nicht
nur unglaubwürdig in sachen finanzen es
ist aus unserer sicht nicht mehr sicher
das verfassungsgericht wird das
bestätigen auch verfassungswidrig und es
lässt mich auch an ihrem ansonsten oft
vorgetragene bekenntnis zur
schuldenbremse zur regel orientierung
und auch zur selbstfindung der politik
zweifel meine damen und herren ich habe
in der debatte zur haushaltseinbringung
im märz bereits gesagt solide finanzen
eine einleitung der schuldenbremse all
das ist kein selbstzweck stattdessen
geht es bei der frage ob und inwieweit
den bundeshaushalt schulden finanzieren
um eine zentrale und auch ganz einfache
frage sollen die herausforderungen vor
denen wir heute zweifellos stehen und
die nicht selten aktuell generationen zu
verantworten haben sollen diese
herausforderungen von uns bezahlt werden
oder von unseren kindern mit ihrem
haushalt und mit ihrer finanzplanung
haben sie sich dafür entschieden dass
unsere kinder bezahlen sollen nicht nur
aber auch deswegen lehnen die ihren
haushalt ab vielen dank
[Applaus]
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
wurde hier hart angegriffen und
unglaubwürdig hingestellt er kann jetzt
auf diese anschuldigungen
reagieren denn natürlich ist das hier
sein haushalt der hier diskutiert wird
für den er auch von der union deutlich
kritisiert wurde die ja auch unter
anderem dagegen klagen möchte also
christian lindner ist jetzt ein
rednerpult
kollege burri ich habe gerne ihren
leidenschaftlichen plädoyer zugehört
vieles von dem was sie gesagt haben
teile ich in der sache auch und dennoch
muss ich noch mal gerade im volks
handbuch nachschauen habe gesehen sie
sind ja jetzt in ihrer ersten
wahlperiode deshalb können sie nicht
wissen dass sie viele dinge kritisiert
haben die ich von der vorgänger
koalition übernommen habe
und das will ich gern in einigen wenigen
punkten deutlich machen der erste punkt
wir haben ja in drei phasen diese
haushaltsberatungen miteinander
gestalten erste phase war der zweite
regierungsentwurf 2022 der entwurf der
ampel koalition wir haben dort die
eckpunkte von 99 7 milliarden euro
nettokreditaufnahme für 2022
fortgeschrieben aber anders als die
vorgänger koalition haben wir andere
schwerpunkte gesetzt obwohl wir im
zweiten regierungsentwurf nicht einen
euro mehr schulden geplant hatten als
die große koalition haben wir eine
bafög-reform realisiert haben mehr getan
den sozialen wohnungsbau wir haben in
klimaschutz investiert und wir haben den
von cdu csu und spd verantworteten
einkommenssteuertarif an die inflation
angepasst um die menschen zu entlasten
alles regierung hat punkten
alles mit ihren eckpunkten und damit
kann ich sagen der zweite
regierungsentwurf
2022 das war bereits der beginn von
konsolidierungspolitik zum zweiten
zum zweiten haben wir ja mit ihren
eckpunkten mehr qualität erreicht das
sieht mal es kommt eben auf den
koalitionspartner an damit gutes bewirkt
werden kann und zum zweiten
zum zweiten ergänzungs haus hat zum
zweiten der ergänzungs aus hat dass die
milliarden für die ukraine drin im
ergänzungs haushalt da sind die
wirtschaftshilfen enthalten im
entlastungsmaßnahmen
enthalten die wir doch alle brauchen
insgesamt
39 milliarden euro an hilfe zur
geflüchteten unterstützung im inland
militärischer ertüchtigung solidarität
mit der ukraine
nennen sie eine maßnahme daraus die sie
nicht wollen oder die die von ihnen
regierten länder nicht gerne auch mit
umsätzen wie das neurotiker
und deshalb meine damen und herren
und deshalb haben wir 139 milliarden
euro nettokreditaufnahme in einem jahr
von krieg und krise nur zum vergleich
wir planen jetzt 139 milliarden euro der
letzte haushalt der cdu-geführten
regierung
2021 da war die planzahl
240 milliarden euro jetzt und jetzt ja
finanzminister scholz ist jetzt der
bundeskanzler
jetzt der bundeskanzler
wir haben jetzt eine andere
arbeitsteilung in der region und jetzt
kommen die 100 milliarden euro für das
sondervermögen bundeswehr hin zu dem sie
ja zu stimmen dem stimmen sie ja zu und
halten es für erforderlich
weil wir damit ja auch eine jahrelange
vernachlässigung der bundeswehr beenden
aber die vernachlässigung
aber meine damen und herren einmal daran
und
haushaltspolitisch hat die
vernachlässigung der bundeswehr doch
noch eine andere seite die
vernachlässigung der bundeswehr hat auch
über jahren auch cdu geführten
regierungen
verteilungsspielraum an anderer stelle
gebracht und deshalb ist nur richtig
dass jetzt zustimmen dass wir diese 100
milliarden euro in die bundeswehr
investieren denn sie bekennen sich dazu
dass sie verantwortung haben sowohl für
den zustand der bundeswehr als auch für
die finanzen dieses landes wie sie uns
hinterlassen hat und
was nun es wird ja zur bilanz dazu was
nun ist die alternative die sie
angeboten haben 60 milliarden euro aus
dem klima- und transformations- von
wollen sie abziehen in diesem jahr
einsetzen dann fehlen uns in den
nächsten jahren die wichtigen
transformativen investitionen vor allen
dingen aber klagen sie ja kollege burri
gegen diese 60 milliarden das heißt die
60 milliarden dies nach ihrer
überzeugung gar nicht geben sollte die
geben sie aber trotzdem gerne aus wie
widersprüchlich ist dies zum 25
dann werden dann werden jetzt mal da und
dann werden alle rücklagen aufgelöst die
wir von ihnen übernommen haben wie
wollen sie denn den haushalt 2023
aufstellen ohne diese rücklagen
einzusetzen ich sage ihnen wir machen es
nicht wie die tageszeitung ihrer
haushalts änderungsanträge landen nicht
im papierkorb die kommen auf die
wiedervorlage für die haushaltsberatung
2023 kommen zum schluss
und bei alldem und bei all dem sind sie
in der lage immer noch mehr ausgaben
mehr entlastung mehr subventionen über
die kfw zu fordern sie wollen in der
haushaltspolitik schäuble sein das ist
ihr anspruch aber die realität ist nicht
schäuble die realität ist wie der
jongleur in der strandpromenade von sylt
so gehen sie mit dem geld der menschen
bundesfinanzminister christian lindner
hat hier seinen haushalt verteidigt auch
direkt verteidigt gegen seinen vorredner
auf ihm direkt antworten wird nun kein
gottschalk der finanzpolitische sprecher
der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
damen und herren vor ort herr dobrindt
es war eine besondere art öffentliche
leben sie haben glaube ich auch eine
netzkarte erster klasse aber ich lade
sie gerne ein wenn sie es machen wollen
dass wir zweiter klasse und
regionalbahnen von münchen nach oben
fahren dann lade ich das sogar auf den
rasen in irland ein arbeit das war echt
voll keine musik in weimar sagt das war
geheuchelt lassen es an der stelle
komme aber zu diesem bundes komme zu
diesem bundeshaushalt verehrte damen und
herren der ja nun eigentlich nicht mal
diesen namen verdient und verballhornung
der deutschen sprache die sie hier ja in
den linken fraktionen so eingeführt
haben zu sagen das ist das gute
haushaltsgesetz aber an diesem haushalt
ist nichts gutes spiegelt nämlich den
linken zeitgeist und seine
gesellschaftspolitische und vertreter
wieder die hier nun sich komplett
durchgesetzt haben meine damen kennen
und diese genau diese vertreter sind es
die auch von den medien als akteure die
sich jetzt davon stehen begleitet worden
sind die an der desolaten verfassung und
dem abwracken der bundeswehr das schon
unter gerhard schröder begangen schuld
haben meine damen und herren sie haben
an der schuldenkrise zur schuld denn die
schon 2009 von frau merkel vorbereitet
worden meine damen und herren um mit
dieser schuldenkrise das wird in jeder
wissenschaftler sagen geht eben auch die
galoppierende inflation dieser tage her
die für armut in breiten kreisen der
bearbeitenden bevölkerung beiträgt meine
damen und herren deswegen fortschritts
koalition herr scholz herr lindner das
sind sie nicht sie sind eine
umverteilungs koalition die eine
reinkarnation darstellt des fünf jahres
plan den wir schon in der ddr gab haben
meine damen und herren
herr lindner
verlieren da sie bezeichnen kollegen
hier im hohen hause als zauberer da
musste ich glatt an johann wolfgang von
goethe denken und den zauberlehrling und
ich sage mal auch der hatte dann
probleme die schulden geister sozusagen
in die koalitionsfrage und die ist ganz
groß zurückzudrängen meine damen und
herren das ist eine misere wir haben
ganz alleine sie zu verantworten
allerdings ein bisschen verständnis fast
mitleid habe ich mit ihm da ist die er
schon fast sozialistisch zu nennende spd
mit kevin kühnert die an dem einen bein
berlin zieht noch weiter links ja es
geht die grünen mit ihren utopie
utopischen öko-förderung ja und dann das
ganz böse wort hier im hause von rechts
kommen dann noch einige ihrer kollegen
in ihrer fraktion die sie ganz milde
aber nur noch an ihre wahlversprechen
von vor nicht mal einem jahr erinnert
ihre wahlversprechen gegenüber dem
fleißigen menschen sind makulatur herr
lindner
diese schulden sind doch in wahrheit nur
der kitt der ire umverteilungs koalition
zusammenhält meine damen herren das ist
die brutale wahrheit über ihre
schuldenorgie die sie hier abbrennen
meine damen und herren und ob sie die
schuldenbremse in den nächsten jahren
einheiten wenn sie haben wir 23 hier im
unter lautem gelächter entsprechend
artikuliert da sprechen sie doch mal
vielleicht mit der grünen-abgeordneten
orte die am dienstag ja schon
wahrscheinlich angekündigt hat was kommt
sie sagte dass ausreichende
schuldenbremse und steuererhöhungen zwar
sogar von kriegs steuern die rede das
wäre dann wirklich politik aller italien
und frankreich einer weichwährung und
verschuldung meine damen und herren und
damit enteignen sie händlern und
fleißiger arbeiter in diesem lande herr
lindner
in zeiten von gravierender inflation wir
haben die höchsten seit über 50 jahren
da brauchen die menschen und der
mittelstand glaube ich andere
bekenntnisse als das was sie hier eben
vorgetragenen viele haben angst um ihr
lebensstandard und ihre zukunft in
zukunft hier gestalten zu können diese
gebeutelte nation hätte eine andere
erklärung verdient wie der sony com
komplett weg bürokratieabbau das wären
botschaften gewesen die für
wirtschaftswachstum sorgen aber doch
nicht eine transformation die beste
transformation die ihre regierung
transformiert sich von heute auf morgen
weg und macht den platz für eine
bürgerlich konservative regierung in
diesem lande frei
abschließend bleibt ein fader
beigeschmack ich sehe hier nämlich schon
jetzt wie sie ihre versprechen brechen
werden und mit tricks und anderen üblen
methoden kommen sie aus dem schein
ausgeglichenen haushalt vorgaukeln
wollen ähnlich ist es ja mit ihrem
verteidigungsfonds oder ihrem
sondervermögen meine damen und herren
das ist kein sondervermögen das sind
sonder schulden zulasten der jüngeren
generation und da machen wir nicht mit
dankeschön
gottschalk war das und mittlerweile hat
auch der kanzler olaf scholz hier der
debatte wieder zu und nächster redner
ist auch aus seiner eigenen partei
andreas schwartz
damen und herren
faktum ist wie die alten römer sagten
die arbeit ist vollbracht jahr
verabschieden nun gleich den ersten
haushalt der ampelkoalition danke vor
allen dingen an die fleißigen
helferinnen und helfer im hintergrund an
unsere fraktions mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter aber natürlich auch an das
ausschusssekretariat ja
mit diesem feuerwerk der guten laune
schaffen wir sicherheit in der krise
reagieren mutig besonnen und
entschlossen diese koalition hat einfach
lust auf zukunft trotz oder wegen aller
herausforderungen wir machen in dieser
koalition den fortschritt und
investieren ca 51 milliarden euro in
unsere zukunft dass es circa ein drittel
mehr als vor der krise klare signale
kommen auch an die kommunale familie
freut mich als ehemaliger bürgermeister
an vielen stellen sie mir gar nicht
zuständig aber wir machen was
beispielsweise
659 millionen für sanierungsmaßnahmen
von kulturellen einrichtungen
476 millionen für die sanierung
kommunaler einrichtungen des parks
ernährungsprogramm mit 100 millionen ja
der haushalt hat ein volumen von
insgesamt fast 500 milliarden die
eingeplante neuverschuldung die haben ja
schon in der gruppe gelegt den pfad
bleibt bei 140 milliarden bei dem was
wir erwartet haben klar wir nehmen
kredite auf aber wir machen was aus dem
geld und investieren in die zukunft
nachfolgende generationen und meine
damen und herren das ist ein guter
haushalt wir machen das zukunfts das
land zukunftsfähig und wir stärken den
zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft
heute haben wir eine schier
unvorstellbare situation in europa aber
auch in deutschland carola krise
angriffskrieg der russen auf die ukraine
und nicht zu vergessen meine damen und
herren die auswertung der klimakrise auf
die laufende transformation man sieht
zeitenwende in allen lebensbereichen und
dieser haushalt erfüllt diese
zeitenwende mit leben und die fragen der
zeit brauchen jetzt fortschrittliche
antworten und wir liefern sie dieses
land ist in der lage sich diesen
herausforderungen zu stellen und
gestärkt aus vielen krisen zu kommen
fährte bürgerinnen und bürger es gibt
auch viele entlastungen wir lassen sie
nicht alleine und reagieren auch hier
schnell und entschlossen und wir sind
bereit auch weiter zu helfen mehr als 30
milliarden wurden hier kurzfristig in
die hand genommen ein feuerwerk an
maßnahmen von heizkostenzuschuss sofort
zuschlag für die familien kinder senkung
der energie steuer 300 euro energiepreis
pauschale 9 euro ticket ja meine damen
und herren mir ist bewusst dass damit
auch nicht alle engpässe in den
haushalten die aufgrund der krise
entstanden sind geschlossen und
beseitigt werden können aber wir kümmern
uns darum wir haben das auch den schirm
und wir reagieren und die menschen
nehmen das auch draußen war sehr geehrte
damen und herren der kampf gegen den
klimawandel der geht weiter auch hier
nehmen wir unwahrscheinlich viel geld in
die hand für elektromobilität für
wasserstoff technologie in deutschland
ja und wir wollen auch dass unsere
gebäude weiterhin effizient ausgebaut
werden die transformation
der wirtschaft ist das zauberwort und
der schlüssel zum erfolg auch hier gehen
wir das signal an die unternehmen aber
auch an die mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter wir wollen arbeitsplätze
sichern und wir werden diesen prozess in
deutschland begleiten
die menschen in unserem land brauchen
sicherheit sicherheit in allen
lebenslagen diese fortschritts regierung
liefert diese wie garantieren somit den
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen stabilität
und somit den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt von der zugspitze bis nach
sylt von aach und bis nach görlitz
dieser haushalt ist zudem ein
meilenstein in hinblick auf die äußeren
innere und soziale sicherheit in unserem
land ich denke am thw fahrzeug
beschaffungsprogramm zoll bekämpfung
gegen geldwäsche schwarzarbeit
mindestlohn kontrolle hier wird personal
aufgestockt ebenso bei der bundespolizei
wenn es um das thema innere sicherheit
geht ja und wir stärken aber nebenbei
noch den sozial wohnungsmarkt wir
starten die familien und natürlich auch
den bildungsbereich meine damen und
herren auch die äußere sicherheit die
muss zusammen mit der inneren sicherheit
ja gedacht werden und die hat auch bei
uns höchste priorität
stichwort ist hier 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen der bundeswehr wir
übernehmen hier verantwortung für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten und senden vor
allen dingen auch ein klares signal an
die bündnispartner in der welt
deutschland erkennt seine verantwortung
ist sich dieser bewusst und ist ein
zuverlässiger bündnis papa das ist das
klare signal dass auch von diesem
haushalt ausgeht liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ich bedanke mich wirklich für
die gute und konstruktive
zusammenarbeit auch über die
parteigrenzen hinweg das ist auch ein
guter ausblick in die zukunft denn nach
dem haushalt lieber bettina hagedorn ist
vor dem haushalt und wir freuen uns
natürlich auf die nächsten beratungen
die in kürze anstehen aber jetzt haben
eine handlungsgrundlage für unser land
geschaffen freuen wir uns darauf setzen
wir um und gestalten die zukunft in
diesem land positiv dankeschön
es folgt jetzt für bündnis 90/die grünen
famila schäfer
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen lieber herr
dobrindt lieberherr buche ich finde es
interessant dass sie sich über die hohe
nettokreditaufnahme beschweren ich bin
mir eigentlich sicher dass dies
wahrscheinlich genauso machen würden so
harten krise dass sie versuchen werden
die würden die erforderlichen maßnahmen
auch zur verfügung zu stellen nichts
anderes ist es was wir machen als
verantwortung für dieses land zu
übernehmen und da würde ich mir ein
bisschen mehr ehrlichkeit in der debatte
würde
wenn ich mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern
in meinem wahlkreis aus dem münchner
süden spreche dann ist es auch ehrlich
gesagt genau die erwartungen an uns die
erwarten dass wir erstens dafür sorgen
dass unsere kinder und enkel am ende
dieses jahrhunderts noch in einer
einigermaßen intakten ökologischen welt
leben können zweitens dass wir die
demokratische selbstbestimmung in diesem
land ausbauen und auch weiter
verteidigen und dass wir dritter auf
diesem weg niemanden zurücklassen und
ich bin mir sicher die erwartungen in
ihren wahlkreisen sind ganz ähnliche
egal ob in münchen bochum sylt oder in
der lausitz unsere politik wird sich an
diesen erwartungen messen
und der haushalt den wir heute
aufstellen wollen der vorliegende
haushalt er muss sich hinter diesem
anspruch auch nicht versteckt und das
zeigte die extra milliarde für die
humanitäre hilfe in der ukraine oder
zahlreiche investitionen in die
energiewende und den internationalen
klimaschutz heute investieren wir auch
mit dem sondervermögen unsere bündnis
und verteidigungsfähigkeit um die
versäumnisse aus der vergangenheit zu
korrigieren
aber wir müssen uns auch ehrlich machen
dass das noch nicht reicht krisen
bewältigt man ja dann am besten indem
man sie verhindert und nicht umsonst
haben wir uns im koalitionsvertrag auf
die eins zu eins regelung gegeben die
auf höchste in der internationalen
krisenprävention und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sichern soll
es ist haushalterisch sind voll dafür
jetzt die finanzierungsspielräume zu
ermöglichen und in eine umfassende
resilienz zu investieren
und dazu gehören eben auch investitionen
in den bevölkerungsschutz in den schutz
kritischer infrastruktur und in dem
sozialen fügen wir zu lange denn am
teuersten sind doch die krisen die wir
nicht verhindern das wissen wir
haushalte am allerbesten
denn die ganzen überplanmäßigen
bewilligungen die linken auf unserem
schreibtisch wenn wir die ganzen gelder
wieder in krisenzeiten lockermachen
müssen deswegen krisenprävention ist
kluge haushaltspolitik
und so teil dieser haushalt 2022 auch
ist wegzaubern wird er natürlich diese
multiplen krisen die wir aktuell erleben
nicht der nächste kabinettsentwurf der
muss deswegen auch auf den entwicklungen
in diesem haushalt aufbauen und ich kann
die liebe kabinettsmitglieder auch nur
ermutigen die verhandlung für den 20 23h
horst heldt so anzugehen dass die auch
der größe der herausforderung gerecht
wird vieles aus dem koalitionsvertrag
wartet oder rauf in dem entwurf der
bundesregierung festgeschrieben zu
werden wir haben die aufgabe die
aktuellen krisen zu bewältigen ohne
dabei neue zu schaffen dafür gehen wir
mit diesem haushalt einen großen schritt
in die richtige richtung lassen sie uns
diese strecke ohne ein tempolimit
zurücklegen für 2023 gilt wer bremst
verliert viel salz vielen dank
jamila schäfer war dass sie sitzt im
haushaltsausschuss um sich vorsitzender
des bundes finanzierungs gremiums also
das gremium das über das schulwesen des
bundes die parlamentarische kontrolle
ausübt nächste rednerin ingeborg gräßle
cdu csu fraktion
schon gewusst dass rot grün nicht mit
geld umgehen kann wem 332 milliarden
euro steuereinnahmen nicht reichen werde
es auch noch durch eine sensationelle
neuverschuldung trocken muss das ist
klar dass das nichts wird aber dass die
fdp damit im boot sitzt zugestimmt und
sich dann als hütchenspieler in der
öffentlichkeit auf führt dann muss ich
sagen haben minister als hütchenspieler
sind sie einfach nicht gut genug
vielleicht sollten sie die entsprechende
fortbildung er in berlin als als
aufsuchen
wir haben gemerkt
wir haben gemerkt dass die großen
verlierer dieses haushalts die rentner
sind die rentnerinnen und rentner
sie haben respekt plakatiert sie haben
plakatiert jetzt kommt die große soziale
gerechtigkeit und genau diese gruppe
fällt bei ihnen durchs raster wir
beraten ja nachher auch noch ihr
rentengesetz in dem allerdings nur
renten löcher gestopft werden statt eine
neue renten perspektive zu geben wir
finden das falsch
die aktien rente der fdp ist offenbar
offenbar ganz beerdigt jedenfalls finden
wir keinen einzigen euro in diesem
haushalt und beim energie geld vergessen
sie ausgerechnet diejenigen die ihn von
inflation und preissteigerungen am
härtesten betroffen sind nämlich die
rentnerinnen und rentner
ich möchte
wir finden das falsch wir haben viele
gute gründe diesen haushalt abzulehnen
ich möchte ihnen aber auch noch ein paar
eindrücke aus meiner ersten beratung mit
teilen dieser haushaltsberatung meinem
25 jährige mit einem 5
925 parlamentsjahr ich kann nur sagen
danke für nichts die mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter wenn die nicht gewesen
wären hätten aber nichts zu beklatschen
gehabt ich muss ihnen sagen ich bin
schon schockiert über die aufgabe von
parlamentsrechten und wie die regierung
ihre government ihren großen apparat
durch die kalte küche nachts um 1 uhr
aufgebaut hat ohne protest von wem auch
immer von den entsprechenden
regierungskoalition ehren die das ganze
durch handauflegen zur kenntnis genommen
und brav zugestimmt hat die 1500 stellen
beim zollen müssen jetzt als
rechtfertigung herhalten verein stellen
auf von 10.000 stellen geht's noch das
ist erbärmlich ich kann
diese wir gehen aus diesem haushalt
heraus mit einem rekord aufwuchs an
stellen mit einem rekord aufwuchs an
stellen die die künftige generation die
nächsten 30 40 jahre belasten werden und
das empfinde ich als das gegenteil von
nachhaltig und ich glaube das wäre
vom verfahren her sie haben doch auch
plakatiert mehr demokratie wagen mir
fortschritt wagen ich finde es als
undemokratisch wenn die vorlagen so spät
kommen dass man sie wirklich nicht mehr
zur kenntnis nehmen kann ich empfinde
das ganze vorgehen als regierungs lastig
und dass ihnen das gefällt glaube ich
sofort aber es macht sie halt auch zu
braven abnicken von regierungsvorlagen
und dreisten versuchen die regierung
aufzubauen und das bei tag und bei nacht
ich kann ihnen sagen ich habe so was
noch nie gesehen und möchte es
eigentlich auch nicht sehen in zentralen
fragen dieses landes sind wir kein jota
vorangekommen nämlich eine frau solche
frage ist ja warum auf manchen haushalts
linien so viel geld vorhanden ist dass
die verwaltung das geld also gar nicht
umsetzen kann da ist es ja mit
schuldzuweisungen nicht getan offenbar
gibt es strukturelle probleme in unserem
land die regierungs unabhängig sind das
betrifft gerade auch die probleme der
digitalisierung die sowohl beim bmf
resultieren als auch beim bmi dann
müssen wir uns zu wenden und es wäre gut
wenn sie hier nicht mit unter komplexen
analysen von glänzen würden nämlich dem
satz wir wollen also geht es und im
umkehrschluss ihr wolltet nicht also
ging es nicht pa und selbstlob werden
diese probleme nicht lösen ich möchte
ihnen sagen was mich wirklich entsetzt
hat in dieser debatte ist wie die redner
der ampel die fakten verdreht haben da
wurde in der generaldebatte behauptet
die union nutze die von uns beklagten 60
milliarden euro für den energie und
klimafonds zur deckung unseres
entlastungspaket
die realität sieht anders aus wir senken
die von ihnen um gebieten mit die
umgewidmeten mittel im rahmen unserer
anträge ab genutzt werden sie rein
haushaltstechnisch damit ihre
neuverschuldung in der vorlage reduziert
wird glauben sie wirklich dass wir ihnen
so eine steilvorlage gegeben sondern
glauben sind es wirklich lesen sie mal
besser lesen sie die dokumente richtig
zu finanz- zur finanzierung unseres 40
milliarden entlastungspaket verwenden
wir mittel aus der rücklage in höhe von
48,2 milliarden euro eine rücklage
übrigens die unter der cdu csu geführten
regierung geschaffen worden die sie
weiter gebunkert haben warum haben sie
sich gewundert weil es sie natürlich
brauchen zur befriedung der koalition
mit geld wir entsprechen wir
entsprechend eine empfehlung der person
des rechnungshofs der us konsum von
rücklagen vor neuen schultern sie haben
wie die eichhörnchen im winter vorräte
angelegt in diesem haushalt
manövriermasse spielgeld und kit für
einen bereits brüchigen
koalitionsfrieden sie ringen halt nicht
um die beste politik sondern es geht
nach dem motto jeder kriegt was und das
ganze ist zum lasten der
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler die
sich schon fragen was aus dieser
koalition noch einen positiven
herauskommen soll das unser land
wirklich weiterbringt dankeschön
soweit die kritik von ingeborg gräßle
cdu csu fraktion auf sie antwortet nun
otto fricke der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der fdp fraktion
also frau kollegin ich will jetzt nicht
sagen dass das
umgesetzte war aber ich will doch gerade
dass wir ein wenig zur haushaltspolitik
zurückkommen und zu den zahlen meine
damen und herren
frau präsidentin ich bitte vielmals um
entschuldigung und bedanke mich ganz
besonders dass ich unter ihrer obhut
reden darf meine lieben kolleginnen und
kollegen ich möchte mich ganz besonders
bedanken nachdem schon vielen dank
worden ist in ausblick der
haushaltspolitik wir haben den haushalt
2022 hinbekommen aber 23 kommt ich
bedanke mich ganz besonders bei dem
hladik leider gerade nicht anwesenden
olaf scholz und bei hubertus heil denn
die beiden haben etwas sehr gutes gesagt
zu 23 olaf scholz bei allem was wir
heute und auch künftig tun ist eines
klar kreditfinanzierte dauersubventionen
sind keine lösung zumal wir nächstes
jahr die verfassungsmäßig
vorgeschriebenen schuldenbremse wieder
beachten werden ziel muss also sein den
inflationsdruck nachhaltig zu mindern
denn das ist der punkt und da hat der
bundeskanzler vollkommen recht der den
bürgerinnen und bürgern am meisten in
ihren sorgen täglich die frage stellt
wie komme ich in die zukunft und die
antwort muss immer im haushalt gefunden
werden und wir als koalition haben die
antwort hier auch in diesem haushalt
kunden werden in 23 auf wiedersehen
hubertus heil hat dann noch sehr schön
heute morgen gesagt zum thema inflation
alle werden beitrag leisten müssen beim
kampf gegen die inflation und das sage
ich wird auch eine aufgabe für die
koalition in den nächsten monaten sein
keiner von uns kann die zukunft
vorhersagen aber wir müssen sie planbar
machen soweit es uns möglich ist und das
tun wir mit einem entwurf eines
haushaltes 23 wo ich mir sicher bin dass
wir in der nächsten sitzungswoche dann
auch wissen wohin die reise im nächsten
jahr geht natürlich immer unter der
voraussetzung dass nicht neue
schicksalsschläge kommen von dem wir
alle hoffen dass sie nicht geschehen
werden und meine damen und herren die
schuldenbremse ist für das thema
inflation deswegen möchte ich das heute
ja nochmal verbinden so essenziell
wichtig denn die verhindert dass wir es
uns ein machen machen als politik sie
verhindert dass wir sagen du hast ein
problem hier ist das geld wir lösen ist
und es wäre ja auch zu einfach und dann
könnte es ja auch jeder dann könnte es
ja auch die cdu wenn man es einfach nur
nach dem motto machen würde einfach mehr
geld ausgeben das werden wir mit
sicherheit ich tun das zweite aber ist
und das will ich doch dann doch noch
deutlich sagen das zweite aber ist nicht
aufregen nicht aufregen ihr habt noch
dreieinhalb jahre wo ich daran gewöhnen
können gemeinsam und herren das zweite
aber ist auch bei der schuldenbremse
wenn in deutschland die inflation nicht
unter kontrolle ist dann wird das für
europa schwer sein wie die inflation
unter kontrolle zu halten und wenn wir
die schuldenbremse nicht nutzen dann
heißt das nichts anderes als dass die
ezb endlich reagieren müsste und dann
leider wenn wir es nicht tun viel zu
stark reagieren müsste was wir aber auch
nicht wollen denn übermäßige zinsen in
europa werden wenn sie durch die
inflation getrieben werden die länder am
rande europas denen wir helfen müssten
erst recht in schwierigkeiten bringen
und das glaube ich will keiner in diesem
hause meinen und herren zum schluss zur
cdu ganz schnell auch ein paar worte sie
machen es wieder mit den 60 milliarden
übrigens zum hinweis mit kleinem schwarz
auf großen grünen ihre zukunft scheinbar
dass sie wieder die 60 milliarden von
denen sie sagen sie sind
verfassungswidrig und nichtig und
schreiben wörtlich wir benutzen sie zur
absenkung der neuverschuldung das war
die cdu politik bei diesen
haushaltsberatungen ich hoffe auf mehr
bei den nächsten herzlichen dank
da hat sich jetzt fricke doch noch mal
entschuldigt denn es ist hier usus dass
die rednerinnen und redner die
bundestagspräsidentin oder die
vizepräsident manier ansprechen da geht
es auch nicht um die person sondern eher
um die würde des amtes deswegen hat man
sich darauf geeinigt
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen kollegen nach wochen und
monaten der beratungen und diskussionen
im ausschuss im plenum und darüber
hinaus sind wir auf der zielgeraden
zur beschlussfassung für den haushalt 22
der erste der ampel neben der üblichen
kritik aus der opposition zu wenig zu
viel zu spät zu früh zu schnell zu
langsam zu hoch zu niedrig fehlende
gesamtkonzeption beschäftigt sich die
unions fraktion ja dieses jahr derzeit
mit viel fragen wie wir diese woche ja
auch feststellen konnten das ist
natürlich ein gutes recht aber ich will
einfach betonen dass wir mit dem
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf über den
wir nachher abschließend abstimmen der
ampel antworten geben und das ist doch
das was die menschen von uns erwarten
antworten auf die großen krisen die
gleichzeitig auftreten den brutalen
angriffskrieg die klimakrise aber
natürlich auch die prokura pandemie die
wir noch immer nicht durchgestanden
haben wir geben auch antwort darauf wie
wir als ampel das zusammenleben in
unserem land besser organisieren wollen
freiheitlicher sozial gerechter mehr
rücksicht nehmen auf andere menschen und
auf unseren planeten und was mich
ehrlich gesagt liebe kolleginnen
kollegen jetzt in dieser debatte
wirklich entsetzt hat ist was frau
grässliche gesagt hat dass wir in der
ampel brave abnicker wären das muss ich
sagen ist schon eine ziemliche frechheit
presse das muss ich einfach mal sagen
wissen sie wir haben in der haben in der
ampel allein im einzelplan 06 über 50
deckblätter also änderungsanträge auf
den weg gebracht zahlreiche
maßgabe beschlüsse so und wir haben mehr
änderungsanträge auf den weg gebracht
als sie aus der unionsfraktion
da frage ich mich doch mal
fleißig wer war richtig gut als
abgeordnete und wer hat wenig getan so
das ist doch die wahrheit und insofern
muss man sagen wir in der ampel wir
nehmen die herausforderung an unserer
zeit an wenn man sich nochmal anschaut
was wir allein im einzelplan 06 im etat
des bundesinnenministeriums auf den weg
gebracht haben dann glaube ich dass das
wirklich gutes und absolut er der kroate
antworten sind auf die probleme unserer
zeit wir investieren massiv in den
zivilschutz in den bevölkerungs und
katastrophenschutz in die bundespolizei
wir schaffen gute rahmenbedingungen für
die aufnahme betreuung und integration
von ukrainerinnen und ukrainer und
anderen menschen wir investieren in
politische bildung in digitales in den
sport während sie beim sport bereich 7
kürzungsanträge eingebracht haben das
ist doch der unterschied zwischen ihnen
und der ampel und
man muss klar sagen eine eine zentrale
lehre aus der krone pandemie ist doch
dass wir dann durch die krise kommen
können wenn der staat
handlungsfähigkeit demonstriert wenn wir
die konjunktur mit klugen investitionen
in zukunftsbereiche wie digitalisierung
transformation und klimaschutz am laufen
halten wenn wir die kaufkraft stärken
und wenn wir den menschen zb mit dem
kurzarbeitergeld sicherheit im wandel
geben wir finanzieren ein
milliardenschweres paket das die
bürgerinnen und bürger in den
verschiedensten lebenssituationen von
steigenden preisen entlastet und das in
diesen tagen volle wirkung entfaltet ich
kann den menschen auf sylt und im
übrigen auch der kollegin paula potter
sagen kauft das neun euro ticket fahrrad
auf der schwäbische eisenbahn von
stuttgart über ulm nach biberach und
erholen sie sich vom strapaziösen
inselleben auf sylt in oberschwaben oder
am boden sind
und
liebe kolleginnen kollegen heute morgen
hatten wir drei abgeordneten aus dem
wahlkreis biberach besuch von rund 20
jugendlichen aus riedlingen mit dem
bürgermeister markt geschafft sie sind
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer am
projekt schule ein projekt gegen
antisemitismus und ich muss sagen ich
glaube ich kann dafür alle drei sprechen
wir waren schwer beeindruckt von dem
gespräch und von dem engagement der
jungen leute die haben sich intensiv
befasst mit jüdischem leben in
deutschland mit antisemitismus und was
man dagegen tun kann und ich möchte
einfach an dieser stelle mein dankeschön
ich denke im ganzen haus zum ausdruck
bringen für diese initiativen die wir
landauf landab haben diese jungen leute
aus dem landkreis biberach haben sich
vorgenommen als botschafterinnen und
botschafter viele schulen und andere
jugendliche zu informieren und mit
zunehmend bei diesem wichtigen thema das
uns doch alle umtreibt und wirklich
große sorgen bereitet die sagen wir
müssen was tun wir müssen es selbst tun
um etwas entgegenzusetzen dieser
besorgniserregenden entwicklung dass wir
immer mehr angriffe haben es
antisemitische art auf menschen und auf
einrichtungen von menschen jüdischen
glaubens das kann nicht so bleiben und
deswegen finde ich es großartig ich will
danke sagen allen die sich für unsere
demokratie und der gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt einsetzen und den feind der
demokratie paroli bieten unser haushalt
bietet dafür im übrigen eine gute
grundlage weil wir solche initiativen
noch besser und größer und mit mehr geld
und stellen unterstützen herzlichen dank
martin gerster ist ja auch noch mal auf
initiativen gegen antisemitismus
eingegangen natürlich werden in so einem
haushalt alle möglichen themen abgedeckt
unter anderem auch die förderung von
gesellschaftlichen engagement
trauriges jubiläum seit 100 tagen wird
das diktatorische regime ein
brutalo berus krieg gegen die
demokratische kleine und es ist so
schrecklich und brutal was dort passiert
hier trotzdem hier noch einmal
festhalten wladimir putin ist bisher
gescheitert er hat bisher seine
kriegsziele nicht erreicht wie keine
besteht fort und das mit großem rückhalt
ukrainischen bevölkerung mit großen
internationalen rückhalt das ist richtig
so und das muss so bleiben
gibt große internationale unterstützung
aus den usa aus europa aus deutschland
aus vielen ländern die unterstützung
humanitärer finanziell
diplomatisch mit scharfen sanktionen
gegen die russische wirtschaft seine
elite den schnellen loslösung
von russischen energie importen auch mit
weiteren waffenlieferung video kleine
zur selbstverteidigung diese
unterstützung müssen und werden wir
fortsetzen und intensivieren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
und das darf gehen wir zentrale
antworten auch in diesem haushalt wir
haben eine milliarde euro die der
finanzminister zu recht beim g7 treffen
versprochen hat in der gleichen sitzung
noch in der bereinigung der haushalt
eingestellt unterstützung der auch reine
für den haushalt diese koalition
unterstützt geflüchtete die bei der
aufnahmen integration in deutschland bei
wohnungen beim gesundheitssystem bei
sprachkursen bei kitas schulen und ich
möchte an dieser stelle danke sagen den
vielen menschen die sich ehrenamtlich in
deutschland unterstützen und helfen
vielen vielen dank dass sie solidarisch
sind
wir haben mit diesem haushalt ein
rekordwert mit 2,7 milliarden euro bei
der humanitären hilfe und wir haben das
auswärtige amt im ergänzungs hause in
der bereinigungssitzung nochmal deutlich
gestärkte komme es auf den rekordwert
von 7,5 milliarden euro beim auswärtiges
amt weil wir jetzt eine aktive
diplomatie brauchen weil wir die
zusammen weil wir zusammenhalten müssen
international gegen diesen brutalen
völkerrechts bruch weil wir
zusammenhalten müssen gegen dem korn
krieg wo wladimir putin hunger als waffe
einsetzt und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass das auswärtige amt und die
außenminister und so unermüdlich dagegen
international vorgehen und zusammenhalt
und deswegen brauchen wir ein starkes
auswärtige amt und das haben diesem
haushalt geschafft
und wir haben auch noch einmal deutlich
das entwicklungsministerium gestärkt
nachdem es deutlich zu gering war im
ersten im zweiten regierungsentwurf der
regierung 2,4 milliarden euro wurden
noch einmal im verfahren draufgepackt
das ist richtig so weil es gerade um
globale gerechtigkeit diesem etat gibt
die 11 lücke ist nun völlig geschlossen
habe sich deutlich kleiner geworden
unsere erwartung ist eben auch dass in
den kommenden haushalt dieser 1 1 zu
gefällig geschlossen wird
und wir haben zwei entlastungspaket in
sehr kurzer zeit in wenigen wochen
haushaltsverfahren von über 30
milliarden euro geschnürt zur entlastung
der bevölkerung und der wirtschaft und
ich begrüße auch dass die
bundesfamilienministerin
weitere ideen zur entlastung für
familien von der krise heute angekündigt
hat wir müssen die menschen in diesen
schweren zeiten sozial gerecht entlasten
sondern der stelle würde ich mir bei der
union auch etwas mehr demut und
selbstreflexion wünschen wir haben eine
schwere krise
aufgrund der pandemie und den folgen in
diesem haushalt wir haben eine schwere
krise aufgrund der massiven folgen des
krieges sozial ökonomisch humanitär und
was wir hier machen ist nicht deutlich
geringere nettokreditaufnahme us
regierung merkel letztes jahr geplant
hat was wir hier machen ist gleichzeitig
natürlich die rücklage für die nächsten
jahre benutzen die die union jetzt
streichen will die angela merkel geplant
hat und wir finanzieren ihre zentrale
bereiche um gegen diese krise anzugehen
und zu investieren und das ist richtig
so und
ich würde mir auch mehr dem und wünschen
weil wir auch mit diesem haushalt und
dieser koalition aber viel weg schaffen
müssen was da 16 jahren unionsgeführte
regierung liegen geblieben ist blockade
bei der energiewende missmanagement bei
der bundeswehr wir haben die große
abhängigkeit und russischen energie
importen die co2 emissionen deutlich zu
hoch beim klimaschutz ist viel zu wenig
passiert und deswegen finde ich muss die
union kann die union in diesem haus ist
berate ich nur fragen stellen an den
kanzler und die bundesliga sondern muss
auch antworten liefern muss auch zeigen
was sie auf 16 jahren auch zum teil
weiter politik gelernt hat
[Applaus]
und
apropos klimaschutz natürlich machen wir
das ganze auch damit südliche meer
versinkt weil das einfach ein extrem
schöne insel ist
und ich war am himmelfahrtswochenende
auch absolut ich habe keine jongleure an
der strandpromenade gesehen aber ich bin
mit fahrrad von wenningstedt nach mist
gefahren es gibt tolle wunderschöne
naturlandschaften bühnen
heidelandschaften und ich bin auch durch
den kleinen ort kampen gekommen herr
bundesfinanzminister und dort habe ich
wenn man sich dort am guckt sieht man
einfach sehr schöne und teure sportwagen
man sieht champagner an jeder ecke man
sieht sehr viel glitzer des karat mein
eindruck herr finanzminister war wenn
man sich die situation vor augen führt
ist glaube ich noch etwas luft oben bei
der umverteilung von reichtum ich mir
wünschen dass er zu gemeinsamen lösungen
der zukunft kommen
ich möchte mich zum abschied
[Musik]
zum abschied meiner rede zu
verabschieden dieses bundeshaushaltes
und zum schluss dieses haus zu erfahren
dass sehr lange waren nach zehn harten
parlamentarischen wochen ganz herzlich
bedanken bei der demokratischen
opposition ich möchte mich bedanken bei
den mitarbeitern es aus der kroatin
vorsitzende helge braun und besonders
möchte ich mich bedanken bei den
koalitionsfraktionen in arbeitsgruppen
besonders bei otto fricke und dennis
rohde und auch den vielen
mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeitern
referentinnen referentinnen wir haben
374 änderungsanträgen dieser fahren auf
die beine gestellt wir haben vielen
diesem abend machen so wie es aussieht
etwas kürzeren abschied ich habe
verdanke ich verstehe dass sie haben
sehr vermögend gegen sie ein verfahren
vielen dank hierfür die zustimmung im
haushalt danke
sven christian kindler war das hier für
die grünen und ein langes wochenende
steht an und da wird sylt noch ein
bisschen häufiger erwähnt als sowieso
schon in der debatte um das neue euro
ticket
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
zeitenwende ist leider abgesagt der
bundeshaushalt
2022 lässt eine überzeugende antwort auf
die herausforderungen unserer zeit
vermissen der haushalt ist ein weiter so
ohne eigene ambition das wäre ja mit
blick auf die vorgängerregierung
eigentlich schon ganz gut wenn da nicht
ja wenn da nicht diese zeitenwende wäre
und liebe frau dr piotta wenn sie eben
100 adenauer angesprochen haben und
haben gesagt hätte nicht so große
herausforderungen vor denen sie jetzt
stehen fragen sie mal die menschen die
nach dem krieg dieses land aufgebaut
haben das war ziemlich
geschichtsvergessen
aber kommen wir zu den aktuellen
herausforderungen da ist vor allem die
inflation zu nennen inflation ist
zutiefst unsozial ob an der
supermarktkasse der zapfsäule oder bei
der heizkostenabrechnung
die gestiegenen preise sind derzeit
überall spürbar inflation trifft alle
aber menschen mit kleinen und mittleren
einkommen besonders und es ist ganz klar
die bundesregierung kann die inflation
nicht alleine stoppen sie ist nicht für
die geldpolitik verantwortlich das ist
die europäische zentralbank diese wird
ihrem vorranging mandat der
preisstabilität
aber früher oder später nachkommen die
geldmengenausweitung stoppen und die
zinsen erhöhen und dann dann wäre es
nicht gut wenn der haushalt nicht
strukturell immer gefesselt ist
überschuldet wäre und das ist die
stellschraube liebe ampelkoalition das
ist die stellschraube weil der sie
aufpassen müssen national wie
international
und es gibt noch weitere wege für die
bundesregierung man muss dieser
inflation nicht so hilflos
gegenüberstehen wie sie es tun und nur
die inflation mit der russischen
aggression zu begründen da machen sie
ist sich ziemlich einfach dass man die
bürgerinnen und bürger kurzfristig
entlastet ist in ordnung aber dann bitte
richtig dies kann politik wie das neuen
euro ticket hilft dann überhaupt nicht
weiter und heißt möglicherweise die
inflation eher an aber vielleicht ist
das ticket auch nur eine möglichkeit
erlitten dass ihre hochzeit erste
klimafreundlich von berlin nach sylt
reisen können
sie persönlich sind auf das nur ein euro
ticket natürlich nicht angewiesen die
außenstelle husum des finanzamtes
nordfriesland hat schließlich noch lange
kein bundesfinanzminister mehr gesehen
ob sie ihre verlobte dabei mitbringen
dürfen das müssten sie in der
rechtsabteilung nachfragen aber ironie
beiseite auch von unserer fraktion alles
gute für ihre hochzeit
aber zurück zur finanzpolitik wie man es
kurzfristig besser machen kann haben wir
mit unserem entlastungspaket gezeigt
abschaffung der kalten progression und
zielgerichtete unterstützung für
familien alleinerziehende rentner und
pendler die ankündigung von olaf scholz
in einer konzertierten aktion mit den
sozialpartnern eine lohn preis spirale
zu verhindern ist löblich mit erhöhung
des mindestlohns machen sie aber heute
das gegenteil
und dass sie nicht die zwölf euro wie
haben die menschen alle verdienen das
ist vollkommen unstrittig sondern sie
lösen etwas in den betrieben aus wie die
lohn preis spirale in deutschland
antreiben wird und ich würde mir
wünschen ärzte mir auch sie würden für
eine konzertierte aktion mit dem
einzelhandel versuchen ich weiß dass ich
schwierig das ist ein schwieriger
gesprächspartner aber ich glaube da
trifft es die gerade die menschen mit
wenig einkommen am meisten das würde
mich freuen wenn wir auch da mal
gespräche führen würden mittel und
langfristig kann man inflation auch mit
einer ausweitung des angebots mindern zb
beim außenhandel zeta ist heute schon
angesprochen worden verhandeln sie bitte
nicht nur mit katar sondern bitte auch
mal mit kanada dass wir endlich in
diesem haus abschließen können und
der wirtschaftsminister ich würde mir
auch gespräche mit der chinesischen
regierung sind nicht um energie sagen um
die frage wie wir es doch vielleicht
hinkriegen trotz der korona politik die
in diesem land gefahren wird dass wir
die häfen möglichst schnell wieder offen
kriegen und die lieferketten wieder
langsam in schwung kommen das würde mich
freuen wenn ich da die initiative
greifen frau präsidentin die viel
abschließen mit dem dank an alle
berichterstatter aller fraktionen der
mitarbeiter unserer ag unseren
mitarbeitern in den büros und den
mitarbeitern des deutschen bundestages
des haushaltsausschusses die uns so
hervorragend begleitet haben schönen
dunk
und es folgt für die spd-fraktion esther
dilcher
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kolleginnen und kollegen sehr
geehrte damen und herren
zehn wochen turbo haushaltsverhandlungen
liegen hinter uns wir haben in dieser
relativ kurzen zeit einen
fortschrittlichen haushalt ausgehandelt
so wie wir fortschritt verstehen für die
einen mehr die anderen weniger arbeit
danke auch an das ausschusssekretariat
für die zuverlässige begleitung durch
diese haushaltsverhandlungen
wir haben
und ich bitte noch mal in die reihen
aber ich sehe ihn nicht wir haben in
dieser woche einen wortgewaltigen des
fraktionsvorsitzenden der größten
oppositionspartei erlebt der seine rolle
dazu nutzt sich selbst weiter zu
profilieren allerdings hat er fragen
über fragen aufgeworfen und das könnte
man entweder als selbstkritik an den
letzten 16 jahren kanzlerschaft von
angela merkel verstehen die für die
derzeitige politische und
wirtschaftliche aufstellung unseres
landes einen erheblichen beitrag
geleistet hat und die dem
fraktionsvorsitzenden seine politische
einkehr auf der berliner berliner bühne
wahrlich nicht leicht gemacht hat oder
aber als ratlosigkeit weil auch heute
bei der cdu/csu keine wirksamen konzepte
für die herausforderungen durch bewohner
und die wirtschaftlichen
herausforderungen durch die ukraine
krieg vorliegen
eine antwort haben wir gerade heute
morgen gegeben wie wir den staat durch
krisen lenken und haben mit der neuen
ampel regierung 12 euro mindestlohn
eingeführt und heute nachmittag steht
die rentenanpassung auf der tagesordnung
mein kollege andreas schwartz hat diese
haushaltswoche wunderbar in kiew
bezeichnet hat feuerwerk in zahlen
zusammengefasst deswegen möchte ich das
hier jetzt nicht noch mal an dieser
stelle wiederholen die services
opposition hat auch das wurde schon
gesagt so wenig deckblätter zum haushalt
abgeliefert wie keine opposition zuvor
auch ein ausdruck davon
vorsicht irgendwo wir haben uns darüber
unterhalten sei ganz brav
selbst nach erkrankungen ab und daher
wirklich nichts für eines ihrer
berichterstatter hat die cdu/csu mit
insgesamt zwölf mitgliedern im
haushaltsausschuss obwohl auch teilweise
noch mehr dasitzen weil er auf die
stellvertreter immer noch irgendwas zu
tun haben nicht fertiggebracht
änderungsvorschläge zu dessen
einzelplänen auswärtiges amt was ich
schon sehr bedeutsam finde und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit zu
unterbreiten und für den kollegen
einzuspringen jetzt stelle ich mal eine
frage aber ich stelle mir diese frage
selbst von der opposition keine
antworten erwartet gab es kein interesse
oder keine idee was hier hätte anders
oder besser gemacht werden können für
mich drängt sich ganz stark der eindruck
auf die kolleginnen und kollegen erholen
sich momentan zumindest mental in der
sommerfrische auf sylt
da ist
schon ganz anders aufgestellt gesine
lötzsch hat immerhin 14 einzelpläne zu
beackern und victor perli 11 einzelpläne
sie haben gezeigt was möglich ist wenn
teamarbeit setzen hier
an dieser stelle möchte ich das meiner
aussagen liebe diese überlegungen
die scheinbar starke stimme des
fraktionsvorsitzenden als einzelkämpfer
ist vielleicht nur für die
öffentlichkeit zu hören wirkung in der
fraktionsarbeit zeigte sie bisher jedoch
wenig
insbesondere wenn man sich manche
abstimmung im haushaltsausschuss
anschaut die ein wenig kopflos und
unabgesprochen schien aber
nichts ist so schlecht dass es nicht für
etwas gut ist wir hatten vermutlich die
kürzeste bereinigungssitzung in der
geschichte und waren freitagmorgen schon
vor 3 uhr fertig dass wir für uns
willkommen sie bitte zum schluss soziale
den genannten auch zentrales thema für
die nächsten haushaltsberatung wird
weiterhin seien in der krise zu
investieren um die zukunft der menschen
in diesem land eine perspektive zu
bieten danke
bester deutscher war das für die
sozialdemokraten hat hier aber besonders
die
linksfraktion gue würde ich die ja mit
deutlich geringerer fraktionsstärke
trotzdem alle einzelpläne bearbeiten
musste und damit kommen wir zum letzten
redner das ist dennis rohde
ich möchte als letzter gegner in diesem
haushaltsberatungen mit mit dem dank
beginn zunächst der dank der aus allen
fraktionen kam und er glaube ich auch
berechtigt von allen fraktionen kam an
das sekretariat des haushaltsausschusses
die unmengen am anträge für alle
aufbereiten mussten die das wieder
hervorragend gemacht haben vielen dank
für die gute zusammenarbeit
gruppen
aber auch ganz eindeutig an die
referentinnen referenten der
arbeitsgruppen haushalt ganz egal ob in
regierung oder opposition an die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
abgeordnetenbüros die viele viele
stunden an diesem haushalt gearbeitet
haben und ohne die dieser haushalt nicht
möglich gewesen wäre auch hier findet
sich müssen hier ihren platz finden
und da er zwar selbst nicht gesprochen
hat aber anwesend ist möchte ich auch
einen dank an den ausschussvorsitzenden
aussprechen ich will ehrlich sagen wir
haben als du angefangen hast mit den
haushaltsberatungen sorge weil du jeden
antrag ganz gründlich hast abstimmen
lassen und wir haben hochgerechnet wo
landen wir dann eigentlich in der
bereinigungssitzung dass wir um 10 43
fertigwaren ist auch dem geschuldet dass
du wie eine nähmaschine die anträge
abstimmen lassen vielen dank dafür
und ich möchte mich bei den
koalitionspartnern für die fähre immer
konsens und sache orientierte debatte
bedanken insbesondere bei sven christian
kindler otto fricke das war menschlich
hochgradig anständig das war
vertrauensvoll vielen dank dafür euch
jetzt wird mit blick auf den haushalt
immer gesagt da jeder sein projekt
bekommen und jede fraktion wollte was
und dann hat der eine bekommen damit der
andere auch aus bekommt ich will sagen
dass in meiner wahrnehmung das gegenteil
der fall war wir haben immer versucht zu
gucken wo sind eigentlich projekte die
uns alle umtreiben wo sind eigentlich
dinge die wir gemeinsam voranbringen
wollen ich will ein paar beispiele
nennen ich finde in der
bundespressekonferenz hat otto fricke
anhand der polarstern zwei sehr gut
deutlich gemacht das ist ein großes
projekt geben kann eine milliarde euro
wo jeder interesse daran hat die
polarstern 2 und sagt immer
forschungsschiff ist ein beitrag zur
forschungslandschaft erst ein beitrag
zur bekämpfung des klimawandels
arbeitsplätze in einer hart und stritten
in einer hart umkämpften morgen wird das
ist ein gutes projekt das wir gemeinsam
voran gebracht haben
oder nehmen wir das jetzt auch
etatisiert 9 euro ticket pro jahr dann
in der debatte auch immer darüber
gesprochen wird das habe ein teil der
koalition als kompensation für andere
dinge bekommen und wo in der
öffentlichen debatte momentan gefühlt
nur darüber gesprochen wird dass das
problem für viele menschen gehen wird
nach sylt zu kommen weil jetzt die zügel
verstopft sind aber auch dieses projekt
warum könnten denn die züge verstaubt
sein weil sich auf einmal menschen
erlauben können durch deutschland zu
reisen die es sich sonst finanziell
nicht leisten können das ist ein
erheblicher gerechtigkeit beitrag
ein gerechtigkeit beitrag dessen nutzung
das klima schützt und der für freiheit
des einzelnen sorgt weil der frei ist
das land zu reisen und auch das
verbindet diese koalition das ist ein
projekt der gesamten koalition
wiederfinden
hier nochmals ansprechen wir haben im
rahmen der parlamentarischen
haushaltsverhandlungen
gelder dem ergänzungs haushalt erst mal
grob etatisiert dann bereits im
einzelnen runtergebrochen insbesondere
haben wir über 100 millionen euro aus
dem ergänzungs haushalt in den etat des
bundesarbeitsministers überführt nämlich
für deutsch sprach förderung und auch
das ist etwas was uns als koalition in
der wahrnehmung und wir wollen dass
menschen die bei uns schutz suchen
schnell die sprache lernen und auch sich
eine perspektive hier arbeiten können
das hat uns kein thema waren wir uns
einig wir wollen dass auch italien die
betriebe zu legen
und das darf man vielleicht aufgaben wir
waren uns an der stelle so eilig weil
wir die gemeinsame überzeugung haben
dass deutschland ein modernes
einwanderungsland sein muss und das ist
es durch diese koalition auch wird liebe
kolleginnen und
wir haben bereits im regierungsentwurf
etwas etatisiert haben was uns auch ein
nämlich die bafög-reform es ist die
gemeinsame überzeugung aller drei
koalitionspartner dass man unabhängig
vom geldbeutel der eigenen eltern
zukunftschancen sich arbeiten können
muss das ein und auch deshalb ist das
richtig in diesem bundeshaushalt
aktivierten wir zulegen konnten
und ja nach der rede des bundeskanzlers
zur zeitenwende haben wir uns auch im
haushaltsausschuss intensiv mit dem
sondervermögen auseinandergesetzt und
auch da kann nicht sagen uns eint dass
wir es richtig finden ist über dieses
über diese funktion eines
sondervermögens zu lösen ist richtig
jetzt zu sagen wir machen dafür eine
einmalige kreditaufnahme weil eben auch
über jahrzehnte kaputtgespart wurde das
kann man jetzt nicht einfach aus dem
kernhaushalt finanzieren und ich will
sagen es über ein sondervermögen zu
finanzieren es wesentlich besser als der
vorschlag von friedrich merz klein und
mittlere einkommen mit zusätzlichen
steuern zu belasten
liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir verabschieden heute einen haushalt
des zusammenhalts wir geben antworten
auf die herausforderungen der äußeren
sicherheit aber auch der inneren und der
sozialen sicherheit und deshalb stimmt
die sozialdemokratische fraktion aus
überzeugung diesem haushalt heute zu
vielen dank
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
während ich diese intensive und faire
aussprache schließe hat vielleicht der
ein oder andere schon das wochenende und
einen freien tag womöglich auf sylt vor
augen aber wir haben doch wir haben noch
eine ganze reihe von abstimmungen
und ich möchte sie jetzt darauf
hinweisen dass wir zur schlussabstimmung
über das haushaltsgesetz
2022 in verbindung mit dem gesetzentwurf
zur ergänzung des haushaltsgesetzes
2022 das sind die drucksachen 1000 1000
2200 1200 1600
2600 400 612 1614 bis 1616
1628 kommen es ist die namentliche
abstimmung verlangt
ich möchte